good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast
happy friday friday
gotta get down on friday yeah that's
right acknowledge the [ __ ]
space that you're in
we made it to friday even though it
wasn't that hard because it was a
four-day work week for us it was a
three-day work week but still
it's a friday nonetheless this one makes
up for all those ones that came
so hard so true i just want to
acknowledge the space that we're in
so much weekend ahead of us alarm free
living that is how the week works we get
two days
where we don't thank you for explaining
to us again we don't have to set an
alarm on my phone it automatically
doesn't have weekend alarms so i'm just
gonna i don't have to remind myself
yeah the week works the worst is that
like because you know we take so many
days off
that like when you have a day off and
then you're alarmed like you forget to
turn the weekday alarm off
yeah like you're up at nine it's like i
might as well just go to work yeah no
i'm pretty
good about that when i need to be but
it's just a beautiful
time to be celebrating a friday so i
just want to congratulate everyone all
of you listening we made it
we made it we really did and just
because it was a short week doesn't mean
we did not earn it so pat yourselves on
the back
close your eyes acknowledge the space
that you are
in you are beautiful you are stunning
you are smart and you are alive
on a friday in june which means we have
two alarm free days coming up
with hopefully stunning weather drinking
weather
just enjoy it breathe it in meditate
soak up each other's awesomeness yes
yeah well i mean we have a lot to
discuss today
obviously the news that you need to know
keeping up with the kardashians
so emotional so emotional um did they
say
it's the finale next week i think so
because this the
title of this one was the end part one
oh it was imagining next is the end part
two
or maybe there's a part three that's
insane yeah
then just call it what it is like not
the finale but no i would assume they
said finale and like coming up in the
finale next week that's gonna be so
crazy
yeah well we have so much to talk about
um also i just wanted to quickly like i
have so many books that i want to read
but like i just have been
acting like a true middle schooler and
watching tv instead but i've been
watching so much tv that we've been
talking about here i finished the
hallston
netflix series it was so good like okay
you will really like it
it's just like one of those stories
about like artists who can't get out of
their own way you know it's like
frustrating to watch the downfall but
you like want him to fail so he can
learn his lesson yeah then he does film
it's like too late you know
snatcher learned your lesson lit i was
literally standing at the tv
learn your lesson and halstein did learn
his lesson but it took a really long
time
um so it was really good i really
recommend that even though ewan was like
really bothering me with his
shitty acting then i started why women
kill on paramount plus i finally
subscribed i had like went once to
subscribe
and i just i don't know why like it's
not like the ten dollars it's just the
principle you know no but i think that
powermount is worth it
well now um they also have yellowstone
don't watch
live younger you don't watch yellowstone
we had this conversation i started it
like
during covet and i literally despised it
which was hard for me because like all
the men on that show were like my dream
men
you gotta give it a little more time
it's so good i literally couldn't like
i had heard that like the first season
was like community theater vibes and
then it like really gets better
who said that who said that who said
that
it's not community theater but it's just
a slow burn
i just don't have you know how impatient
i am like i can barely watch a movie
that's over two hours
sickening farm gem and vibes that's
literally why i watched it i was like
give me the farm champion vibes and
honestly the vibes are so [ __ ] sick
like
no i know maybe if i have time but i
have so much on my now that you're on
paramount like maybe they'll influence
you well so i started why women kill
right
it's so good it really is like a mix of
mad men and desperate housewives like
you can really see the mark cherry
influence there's so many similarities
i mean it's an interesting format like
the show is not like a typical
show it's like three different stories
being told like you know when you read a
book from like two people yeah you
always end up liking one perspective
better of course
and there's just like one perspective
that like i just can't stand it's like
the modern one it's like i love like the
50s and then
lucy lou is like so fabulous in the 70s
like and then it's like the modern one
and i'm just it's like the guy from veep
and i'm just like bring me back to the
fabulous eras like this is not fabulous
got it okay i'm gonna watch it i'm so
glad that you took my recommendation
that i was so persuasive
well olivia actually has been telling us
to watch that show and like when i told
her i was watching it she was like
i'm gonna get jackie told me to watch it
she's like no i literally told you to
watch it two years ago well apparently
like there's already two seasons and
someone commented that olivia had been
like telling us to watch it i had never
heard of it so like every time i don't
know where i was when she told us no
because you were talking about it
yesterday like it was a brand new show
and i'm like no i think that it's
like been on i have never heard of it i
love a mark cherry
hour long abc drama like that is
where i want to die on one of the sets
like in the fantasy worlds
of the santa barbara house or wisteria
lane like
he really knows how to paint a picture
yeah definitely
i think maybe i'll watch out this
weekend i was gonna read but we'll see
where the weekend takes me
yeah i finished like i right now i'm
ready to start a fresh book we actually
have some book news so i'm really
excited
to get into the stories we have two book
news stories both i think are really
going to excite you well we're just
covering all of our bases today because
we have book news but i also have sports
news because like
it's nba playoffs and like ben is just
like making me watch it and i'm not
gonna lie like i don't
hate it there's so many celebrity
tie-ins so last night it was the lebron
james versus the kendall jenner
boyfriends
and it was a fascinating game because
lebron james lost which is like
i think he played for these days the
lakers
and devin booker who's kendall's
boyfriend she was sitting in the front
row
he had like the best game of his life
and it's like is it because kendall was
there like he was playing like
breaking records like in the first half
he had like 30 points and like
11 3s or whatever um and like
not gonna lie like i didn't think he was
that cute i mean
love is blind i guess but he was playing
really good and he beat the lebron james
in the whole series like the series over
lebron's not moving forward
in the competition interesting yeah i
just thought it was interesting like
because they say goat but do goats lose
well
these things weren't adding up for me as
someone who doesn't know like about
every season
can he win you know so but that is
interesting
yeah no it was good for devin good for
kendall's boyfriend good for kendall
because honestly if they had lost
everyone would have blamed it on her
being yeah like jessica simpson tony
romo
eek so i'm happy for her that she didn't
have to deal with the anxiety of that
that is so true because people are
always like the kardashian curse so like
sir looks like kettle's reversing it no
with celebrities when they show up for
their men and their men play badly like
it's always
it's so wrong it's so wrong it's so
wrong
like literally jessica simpson couldn't
go to tony romo's games anymore because
she would get booed out of the stadium
i think that was like one of my favorite
parts of jessica simpson's book was the
tony romo of it all because i remember
that like very brief relationship
and thinking it was literally a match
made in heaven like a southern belle and
the dallas cowboys quarterback like
what's not to love and it's so nice to
know that like even for her it wasn't
the
right relationship but it was a really
good one yeah and also i always think
about the fact that she said
that tony romo had like 15 50 000
checks like just like as bookmarked in
books like next to his toilet
like he like lived in a frat house and
like wouldn't deposit them that's funny
that that's what stayed with you because
what stayed with me was like he didn't
know how to put up drapes so he
literally covered like his
floor-to-ceiling windows and trash bags
yeah and which is literally what i did
like a few years ago and also that she
bought him a boat and then they would go
out
on it with their friends and he would
play her songs on it oh my god that's so
cute so cute she's a pee job need
another book from her okay
she has more to say okay that's this
leads right into our first story so
without further a do to do where are you
didn't come in today wanted friday off
he said mom summer fridays let me live
you said fine he said mom my back hurts
because you and jackie are constantly
like phoning it into the show and like
relying on me to provide entertainment
when i'm literally just a dog
that's literally what he said to me okay
dude
and then he also said mom you're not
like other girls and i said thank you
for noticing honey
because you know what i'm not like other
girls no you're not and i don't want
anyone out there to think that she is
because i'm not because she's not i'm so
glad we're on the same page and i know
somewhere no
somewhere there's a person who thinks
that you are like other girls and you
know what they're wrong
but i also know that somewhere do is
watching this show so i just want to say
do
take all the time you need live your
best life hot due
summer without further ado summer for
sure
without further ado here are the fast
five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
if somebody tuned into the show for the
first time like 45 seconds ago they
would literally think we were martians
we are not speaking english
that's why it's good morning millennials
oh good morning
you guys if you're just tuning in to the
show the reason why we say it like that
oh this is a nice little backstory our
show has grown so
much and i feel like there's a lot of
people who like we need to do another
like patreon steamy lexicon episode
because we talk so
strangely and if you're just tuning in
you literally won't understand we're not
speaking english like half of the
episodes
but just a fun fact the reason why we
say good morning millennials in the
beginning of the show the way that we do
is because when we were trying to think
of names for this show like three years
ago three years ago
obviously we settled on the morning
toast but i think was my husband
suggested
good morning millennials like good
morning america and we speak to the
millennials good morning millennials and
we did like it and we were like oh
that's interesting and then ben came in
he was like
good morning millennials sounds like if
an alien came down to earth and was
trying to blend in they'd be like
good morning and ben is like walking
around the living room with his
fingers on his forehead good morning
millennials and we thought it was so
funny
honestly good morning millennials would
have been a good name for the show
except we're limiting like
we have boomer toasters we have gen c
toasters not as many as
i would like yeah but like we're an
inclusive show like we're not trying to
exclude different age groups 100
so that's just your toast fact of the
day that's just a little bit about us
um today's episode before we dive in is
brought to you by bruce and i'm very
excited because i finally got my new
bruce yesterday and you're right i
haven't got a new brush
in like over a year and i forgot how the
packaging i feel like it's been elevated
because it was so
christmas like it was just stunning the
packaging it was really just like a
journey to
open and they came out with three brand
new colors i got the green dream
oh you did i got the mauve no i know and
i'm really feeling the new aesthetic
so this spring you can drift into a
dreamy state of mind and reset with
froosh
new limited edition colorways inspired
by a dream like surrealism so the new
colors are grey mist
green dream which is what i got and
mauve cloud which is what jackie got
the bruce is the best electric
toothbrush on the market take it from us
it works super super well it has an
amazing aesthetic it looks great on your
counter
and it is so much more affordable than
most of the other electric toothbrushes
on the market which can cost over two
hundred dollars
the brush itself has six unique modes to
customize your brushing experience
and a two minute timer for a complete
even clean in your entire mouth
which sometimes i feel like there's
literally no way to know how
long you're brushing your teeth it's
like have i been am i gonna be late or
am i gonna be early cause you really
just don't know
the battery life lasts four weeks and
the magnetic charging stand is so
elon musk approved it's like stunning um
and it comes with a compact travel case
so you can take it with you wherever you
go
they also offer a subscription program
so you'll never have to forget to change
your brush head again because bruce will
ship you a new replacement head
every six months so you're never stuck
using a worn down brush head their sleek
design has a modern aesthetically
pleasing design and it comes in trend
driven seasonal colors
that look great on your bathroom counter
these new colors are only available for
a limited time
so get them before they're just a
distant dream get 15 off your brush
toothbrush kit and the refill plan when
you use promo code
toast at bruce.com that's 15 off using
promo code toast at brush.com
love it okay first story which is the
perfect
first story after our conversation about
how much we love jessica simpson's book
paris hilton sells her memoir to the
imprint behind jessica simpson's book
oh wow harris hilton has just sold a
memoir to the same publisher as jessica
simpson's recent bestseller
william morrow imprint day street books
page six has learned
simpson's book came out in february 2020
and was a number one bestseller and it
was jackie ashrae's second favorite book
that she read in 2020.
and claudia ashley read it when she was
in a really dark place in the hamptons
and it was so good and uplifting and it
was jack ashery's first favorite book
that came out in 2020
because my first favorite book that i
read was an old after hilton shopped the
memoir via lit agent albert lee
of the uta and the upcoming publication
was acquired by day street's editorial
director carrie thornton
day street describes hilton's memoir as
both searingly honest and deeply
personal
and adds hilton will share the real
paris hilton as her celebrity persona
evolved
a publishing insider told page six when
the book was being shopped that it would
try and capitalize on the success of
jessica simpson's book and nostalgia for
early 2000's era pop culture so what's
so funny about this is i'm pretty sure
after we read jessica simpson's book we
were like listing off celebrities who
we'd like to see this
from and i'm pretty sure we said paris
hilton well because paris is in such an
interesting part of her life i feel like
for so many years she was so famous for
this persona and now she's kind of
even more famous for like lifting the
veil on the persona and getting to know
like the real paris hilton it's kind of
like a genius marketing
it's really like added a lot of
longevity to her career
and i think that what a lot of people
have been surprised about
from her documentary and just like
following her on social media and her
projects these last couple years is that
she's actually
so different from the girl like who we
know who used to wear juicy track suits
and flip phones and like a paparazzi
outside of ledu or whatever that place
was called so
i think there's a lot that can be uh
told in the story of course like
the iconic feuds lindsay paris nicole
um but then also like hashtag who is the
real paris hilton so i think this is
just like another
extension of this journey she's been on
yeah and i think it's going to be great
because
if there's anyone who has stories to
tell it's paris hilton for sure and if
it's in the vein of jessica simpson's
book and
i don't know if the book's already
written but the person who jessica wrote
her book with like her ghostwriter i
thought did such an amazing job
um and so i hope that you know day
street
recommends that person as well yeah um
and also i just thought we weren't going
to get something like this from paris
hilton because we recently got a
documentary and this is a podcast
and so i thought that those would be the
mediums through which she decided to
tell her story
but i think a book is exactly what the
doctor ordered yeah and her and jessica
simpson are actually really similar to
me
because they both like come even though
they were in like different
circles they come from like an era of a
time when like
these young girls got famous so fast and
so famous and we're kind of like
tortured by the media and a lot of them
like
did not come out on the other side in
the best
like mental space and i feel like
jessica and paris are both like
survivors almost of it and they came out
on the other side
and like have successful businesses but
like you can't help but compare like
a paris hilton to a lindsay lohan yeah
and they're both like so different you
know
right no i think everything about this
is everything of the source
i hope that it comes out asap yeah
that's all i hope for
there's a lot of it's so funny i used to
like exclusively read celebrity memoirs
and now i haven't read one in so long
like i've been meaning to read
colin jost i heard it was so good and
gabrielle unions and i just like i can't
be bothered i'm just like a literature
queen now no i know what you mean i used
to only read them too
and now it's like i i can't people yeah
unless like if you know andy cohen
released a new book i would like drop
everything and read it
right right exactly it depends on the
person it does but also andy released
another book
true we're ready are you ready for our
next story which is also some book news
sure hulu is already adapting taylor
jenkins reads
malibu rising as a tv series okay we
spoke about malibu rising yesterday it's
the newest book from taylor jenkins read
who also wrote daisy jones on the six
and the seven husbands of evelyn hugo
the best book ever it's funny how
someone could literate the best book
ever and the worst book ever jason jones
in the six like i will stand by that
like
literally hated it so much i i know it's
your favorite book
you're attacking people that's what i do
here welcome to the morning toast good
morning millennials i'm about to attack
you
um i liked both books but i liked evelyn
hugo more if i don't watch why women
kill this weekend i will be reading
malibu rising
me too she's like just like the it
author of the moment she is among the it
authors and everyone's been waiting for
this book and if you read the other two
books
you'll recognize the main character in
this book because he was uh featured in
the it's like mickey rory yeah he was
like
evelyn's like husband second husband and
rock and roll
yeah and i think he like cameoed with
daisy jones and the six whatever he did
author taylor jenkins reads recently
released novel malibu rising is being
developed as a tv series for hulu the
potential series was bought preemptively
by the disney owned streamer in advance
of the
book's june 1st publication i just want
to say like we've
talked so much about like popular books
you know rhys picked it up or hulu
and literally they never happened like
yeah i feel like i
i heard so long ago this summer i turned
pretty like was gonna be at amazon i
haven't even heard a single thing about
it like
i feel like all we do is hear about like
people picking things up and i think
that's just how it works in hollywood
people like buy rights and with
sometimes no intention of ever making it
happen or with the intention of making
it happen it just doesn't happen so many
things have to go right for it to
actually get to our screens
so i agree this doesn't necessarily mean
there'll be a show but i think they will
but
and you know they're coming out with the
daisy jones in the sixth show
i don't think i will be watching that um
i mean it's been in the works for a
while but i just feel like justice for
evelyn hugo
i completely agree because i could see
evelyn hugo literally being an
oscar-winning movie like
stunning so amazing and what's so crazy
is i followed
taylor jenkins read on instagram and it
wasn't until a few months ago
that evelyn hugo hit the bestsellers
list yeah and when did it come out
years ago yeah it's so good like we just
need an evelyn hugo
movie or series i'm happy for all the
other series
right but where's evelyn who goes
justice for evelyn i think we need a
movie evelyn hugo not a series like it's
so elevated
it's so so good yeah and it's all about
movies like
it would be great it would be amazing
yeah so that's exciting
malibu rising um so much book news
news we're just a couple of book nerds
bookworms because you know
we're not like other girls no we're not
and it's never too late to become a
redhead
ever everyone is loving the new episode
everyone is loving the book not everyone
is loving the books i know that a lot of
people were like struggling with it but
keep pressing on american duchess and
then you'll join us for our next book
too but like
yesterday i was literally making content
for the redheads instagram and i was
going down like such a wormhole about
the history of the book that we read and
it was just so fascinating that was
literally me
watching halston because i'm like no way
some of this [ __ ] happened and i want to
see pictures of like all these fabulous
people at studio 54 and the way they
you have like an image of your head of
like what studio 54 was yeah like
or like what the building inside like
actually looks like
sure glitz and glam yeah and they just
like really i feel like portrayed it
exactly how i thought it was gonna look
like
maybe a little bit bigger but there was
also like a crazy story i meant to look
it up if it was
real um this doesn't spoil it or
anything but there was
studio 54 that got shut down um
because in the show like liza minnelli
like fainted because she was like on
drugs or whatever
but they found like a dead girl in the
vents because she was like trying to
climb through she was like this
desperate girl to like get into the club
and she like snuck in and
went through a vent and i guess she like
got stuck in there and died
but i didn't know if that was a true
story dead girl vent
studio 54 i'm not the first person to
search this did a woman sneaking into
studio 54
die in the air vent thank you the
rap.com for wondering the same thing as
i did
um did this happen yes and no in the
real actual version of history most of
that did happen but it didn't happen all
at once got it got it there was a night
of 1978 police raided studio 54 to
collect evidence
got it got it wow it was a crazy
um story and i'm like you can't just
make this [ __ ] up like this had to have
happened
um okay i definitely will watch that and
i just want to share one interesting
fact from the book that we read
um american duchess because she marries
the duke of marlborough who lives at
blenheim palace
blenheim palace plenum palace and then
later on in the book his
um spoiler alert second wife is breeding
cavaliers at she turns the whole palace
into like a
she's like sounds like a dream yeah no
but it wasn't it was kind of a nightmare
and then i was like is there a
correlation between cavaliers and
blenheim palace
and the blenheim cavaliers which theo
and bruno are blending cavaliers
it's the mix of brown and white that's
what it's called they are named for
blenheim palace
wow oh my god so basically my book is
about theo
your book is about theo and bruce and
that's kind of the message
here through this piece of literature
but a larger theme for
all of life everything is about our dogs
a hundred percent
and i just thought that was such a fun
fact so rich in history
oozing with rich historical context
a hundred percent and also like brew was
so excited to learn more about his
history
his family yeah yeah it was really
beautiful he didn't even need to go to
ancestry.com he just had to pick up that
book
yeah so you just learn something new
every day you really do
are you ready for our next story is it
the next story that's brought to you by
echelon
yes it is have you been working too hard
and not working out enough
we've if you've wanted to get in shape
but don't have time to get to the gym
echelon brings the gym to home when
you're trying to reach your fitness
goals it can be really helpful to have
instructors like nicole griffin and
michael brown alongside a community of
25 000 members who can give you that
extra push
and echelon gives you just that the
affordable way to get the workout
equipment the workout community and the
instructor's motivation right in the
comfort of your own home
the echelon fitness app provides you
with thousands of live and on-demand
classes with great music from your
favorite artists
with echelon you can work out any time
day or night and crush your fitness
goals
just pick your class climb the
leaderboard cheer each other on and give
it your all
you can track your workouts and your
progress to reach your fitness goals as
well
they have a full range at echelon of
affordable workout equipment including
stationary bikes
smart rowers sleek fitness screens or
the auto folding treadmill which is
great if you live in small spaces like
new york
they are all connected with the echelon
experience with around-the-clock classes
for the family including full-body
workout programs that keep you coming
back
one membership covers a family of five
so this is the best way to work out
um period and especially if you're on a
budget the membership covers a family of
five
all of the uh stationary bikes all of
their equipment is
super affordable and our listeners can
get a special podcast offer from echelon
because for a limited time only you can
start your 30 day risk free trial
offer with echelon's ex3 bike for just
one
dollar yes that is correct a special
risk-free offer to get 30 days
with echelon's ex3 bike for only one
dollar to start plus free shipping
the only way to get the special offer is
by going to echelonfit.com
toast spelled l
o e-c-h-e-l-o-n f i t dot com slash
toast
echelon fit dot com slash toast that is
a
sickening off that is a great offer i
don't think it gets any better than that
no i mean it how could it okay ready for
our next story the police were called to
jojo siwa's star-studded pride party for
a medical emergency
police and paramedics were called to
jojo siwa's la home where she was
hosting a party celebrating pride month
after receiving a call about a medical
emergency an la fire department
spokesperson told e news that on the
evening of wednesday june 2nd they
responded to a medical call from the
house
about an approximately 30 year old man
they added that he was transported to
the local hospital
his identity condition and ailment were
not disclosed no arrests were made
he had reached out to jojo's team for
comment
but look at jojo just having a making
headlines making headlines like having a
wild party no i saw pictures it looks
like so jojo i mean
everything jojo see what touches looks
like a pride event because it's just
like rainbows and sparkle
um but this was an actual jojo siwa
pride event and i'm sure the budget was
extraordinary because like just the
balloons the decor
it was pretty stunning and she wore a
gucci
pride like they have like a new shirt
it's like rainbow monogram and she
looked
so cute and her girlfriend was there i
saw the gucci fit and it looked
like such a good party like one of those
parties i'm like i think i would have
liked to have been invited to that you
know oh yeah that's a good one she also
recently turned
18 because i was curious about her age
she's like having like a big party yeah
but she's you know a young adult now
and there's a little bit more news about
her she's like starring in a film
um bounce i don't know but she
is uh like has a love interest in the
film that's a man
and i believe she is in the process or
has asked the
writers and producers to like cut the
kissing scene out
yes i saw that this morning they said
that they won't make her kiss
um the man in the new movie they're 100
they're a thousand percent supportive
she said
i mean jojo siwa is literally like a
queen like i'm obsessed
she really really is i'm so happy for
her like and
everything that's going on for her yeah
and i just i hope at the end of the long
day
she's in the tub with her segs with her
sick chain smoking now she has a partner
to chain smoke with i
i hope her girlfriend smokes as well
because they you know
relationships are all about you know
having things in common and i think that
would be important
um i just would like to use the teeny
boppers as a
uh launching pad for an update on a
story i was explaining to you
i mean it's gotten so dark like this
this is the tic tac drama claudia was
sharing in the episode claudia explains
it all
so i had the last we left off was sienna
released
a video statement aggressively denying
all of these claims supporting it with
you know facts and schmacks and all this
stuff and figures facts and figures
and then there was silence until there
wasn't
another one well i knew it wasn't over
another one of jack's friends who was
sienna's ex-boyfriend
um and for context sienna has been
trigger warning accused of sexually
assaulting her ex-boyfriend jack
by multiple people um she denied it and
then another one of jack's friends
posted a tick tock and then deleted it
which is just like
people keep doing this like just leave
it up you know yeah um
what he said was video evidence of the
night where they claimed
the uh event happened it was
a really difficult video to watch um
and then sienna came back again sienna
should be a lawyer like
she's churning out these videos
on all her platforms and
denying denying denying so i don't know
really where we go from here we have not
heard from jack
who's kind of at the center of this
entire
conversation and it's like is all these
videos his friends are putting out is
that him kind of communicating to his
friends does he just not want to talk
about it
um because it's a very sensitive subject
and i just think the teeny boppers are
quaking like they don't know where to go
from here yeah because it's a very
sensitive subject
yeah so i'll of course keep you abreast
on what the kids are up to
thank you so much for this updated
report that is what i do
gen z i've got us covered
okay next story a little biz news a
little
biz news um lululemon is having
sickening first quarter sales they rose
to 88
stopping estimates as store traffic
rebounds now i know that
this jump wasn't due to you why would
you say that
because you just look at my outfit today
you rolled your eyes
so heavily but i do think it signals a
trend
in fashion and a change
as we enter this post-pandemic world i
agree i mean it's
i wish that you know ball gown sales
were up because like
okay yeah people are leaving their house
but according to the sales reports
they're just going to work out so
therefore i'm still in my home no i
think it's like you know that look of
like looking like you're working out yes
of course
but um of course this is great it's
joggers is it
september spring summer joggers
september she was trying yeah okay
um this is great i just like have a
problem with lululemon
okay and i don't think that should come
as to me lululemon
is the restoration hardware of
athleisure what's wrong with restoration
hardware
they're so expensive like honestly
offensively expensive
and they also drive up prices of like
normal furniture because like
you know if restoration hardware is
charging
twenty thousand dollars for a couch
which is literally what they charge
twenty thousand dollars yeah like
literally sectionals like five thousand
dollars per section
okay so you need like at least four okay
three if you're poor like you know
so and then people are obsessed with it
so it just drives up the i have a whole
rant on my instagram stories about
restoration hardware like i went to a
restoration
hardware outlet store one time because
i'm like all right i would never buy
anything from restoration hardware
let me buy from the outlet i walk in i
just look i didn't even like the couch i
don't know why i looked at the price tag
it was like
very honestly very halston it was like
low to the ground
gray leather like puffy it was so ugly
and had a big old [ __ ] stain on it
because it was
outlet i want you to guess how much it
how big was the couch a small sectional
not huge was it the cloud no no it was
like a different design like when i
hadn't seen
eight grand 18 at an outlet store with a
[ __ ] stain on it okay
so this just that's what kind of started
my whole thing against restoration
hardware just really feeling like it was
driving up prices of other stores
because people are obsessed with
restoration hardware and it's just like
not good for the furniture economy
are you following my thesis okay i'm
following and you're entitled to your
opinion i don't know if i agree
i don't care because i'm still in the
middle of my whole thesis
so therefore i think that lululemon is
adapting the restoration hardware model
where it's like okay what's that
lululemon that you literally can't get
at target like
bras leggings that are
cute like they literally sell that at
target they literally sell it at walmart
but lululemon has driven up the price
like 150
per [ __ ] butter legging that are like
i have one pair i didn't purchase
somebody gave me them as a gift
because i i'm true to myself um and like
they're kind they're
good leggings like no they're really
[ __ ] good leggings and honestly
honestly i hear what you're saying but
also i think when something is so
expensive it also leaves space for
someone to come in and be like
we have the same but for much much less
enter
athleta a brand that was i believe built
on the backs of people who
like to the lemon and who didn't want to
pay 150 for leggings or could it pay 150
for leggings and i think athleta is a
great brand
i agree with you i like to diversify
when it comes to my workout clothes but
because i wear so many different brands
i can really tell the difference
and i just want to say like those
lululemon lemon leggings one like really
hold your [ __ ] in
and two i've probably worn them over 100
times and like
they are still they're still good as
opposed to like i wore a pair of like
cheaper leggings
once i was playing pickleball and i just
like slid across the floor
rip okay i'm not saying you need cheap
leggings by any means and i would like
to offer a bottle because i'm someone
who has a lot that needs to be held in
arguably a lot more than you and i wear
dance skin leggings
dan's skin is dense skin doesn't hold
anything oh
your mind has been indoctrinated with
the gospel
and the ducks of lulu lemon corp and you
are a mole
and you have been sent here to push
lululemon products
on us dan skin is what i wear when i
want the look of leggings but the feel
of sweatpants
oh that just cuts me to the core how
you've been so misled jackie
i'm i'm gonna cry you've been misled
indoctrinated
i just feel next thing i'm gonna come to
your house you're gonna have a [ __ ]
cloud couch
for restoration hardware oh no i don't
own anything from restoration hardware
me neither and that's like my thi like i
feel like proud of myself i know but
like
let the people who want to shop at
restoration hardware shop there
of course but they just need to
understand that like it has
repercussions
for us mere mortals like it does drive
up like a couch a regular couch should
cost
a thousand dollars and a really nice
couch should cost
five thousand but like why should a
couch cost twenty thousand dollars like
to me that's just basic principles basic
economics i took econ 101
in in college and i just don't think my
professor would be too happy to hear
about this
well i think he would be because their
restoration harbor my professor was a
she
would be extreme jackie why did you
assume my econ professor was a man
because you said that she was a woman
and she was really mean okay i think she
would
she would say you know what where it's
supply and demand like people are buying
the [ __ ] that's
true restoration is really successful no
that's true as well
and honestly like i'm just i'm such a
principled person
like i really want to go to the rooftop
the reservation hardware rooftop but you
can't get in
excuse me no it said i have principles
but what's what's your principles
against their restaurant it's a whole
franchise
i can't just support you know like i'm a
principled person i really don't have an
issue
with restoration heartbreak like i think
that their stuff is like so nice for
the people who like whose vibe that is
it's stunning you know i obviously just
don't like it because i'm like jealous
yeah no but i'm not everything in my
house is from wayfarer amazing gallery
girlie
like there's so many great furniture
options i feel like it's never been a
better time to be a furniture consumer
like not only
are there so many different price points
like wayfair joss and maine are
all modern all delivered like it
probably used to be so crazy like having
to buy a couch in the store and then
like put it on your
truck roof no no do you drive it wait
four to six weeks like that's literally
yeah
that's what it is it's a great time to
be a furniture shopper it is so many
options
i'm just feeling like being negative you
know oh well yeah you should have said
so i should have led with that
anyways lululemon is doing really well
and i just think it signals that like
people are just
going to be wearing leggings and
sweatshirts and i don't know how i feel
about that
i know it's just like what happened to
class yeah
and also everyone keeps saying that like
now in the post-pandemic world it's
gonna be the roaring 20s but like then
let's get our fashion in check
yeah no because they were rolling into
the roaring 20s like in our athleisure
yeah because they were wearing like
jewels and sequins and dresses
and we're going into the roaring 20s
wearing sweatshirts and loungewear
i just know they can't be roaring if
we're really wearing sweatpants
yeah so i mean look at us we're both
wearing like very relaxed well that's
also because it's friday and the weather
was bad and i was like
it's a summer friday so less people are
going to be like watching on youtube so
i'm not going to waste a great outfit
no that was literally my thought process
our millions of viewers deserve better
they do than these outfits i've been
just turning out some shitty ass outfits
this week
i i take responsibility i really do
we're in transition i wasted all my good
outfits on my weekend plans and you know
what
that's probably going to be my whole
vibe moving forward so just expect me to
to be looking like an
actual piece of [ __ ] on the show and
then like a stunning beautiful and smart
social line on the weekends
yeah you know what i like to do or i
used to like to do it's like if i well
we actually did go out last night so
like
when i went out last night like to wear
that same outfit on the show yes the
next day
yes but your outfit last night was too
fancy for a friday show
a hundred percent i thought the same
thing as well even though i literally
hated my alpha last night
zap we that outfit is so iconic it's
fine
watch her um the patreon blog where i
style claudia
also there's a new patreon vlog um i
don't think we've spoken about it our
last one of the month for last month was
olivia's home tour we finally got to see
kate's nursery olivia's new home she
moved
during the pandemic um and it was such a
cute video like just obsessed olivia
cute
so many cute trinkets in kayla's room
you can see so many of the gifts that
we've got for her and like she just
loves to have them all on display
cause she's on display on display on
display
each and every day every day day
are you ready for our fifth and final
story that's going to lead into our tv
recap yeah
kim kardashian says she feels like a
failure amid relationship
troubles with kanye west okay so yeah
let's dive into our keeping up the
kardashians recap because that scene was
like really heartbreaking yeah
and i feel like it's really appropriate
given the episode that we watched last
night that today's
tv recap segment is brought to you by
legacy box oh my god yes
right they made the time capsule
honestly like after the kardashians pick
up their time capsule in 15 to 20 years
they're gonna have to use legacy box
because the title
the technology will have changed 100
give the gift of memories this year for
an anniversary
you and your spouse will never forget
isn't ensuring that your family's legacy
is digitally preserved so it can be
passed down just as important as
creating the memories
once you revisit these moments you'll
realize just how much your past is worth
saving
so legacy box is a way for you to easily
and affordably digitally preserve your
past
the process is super easy start to
finish so if you have
home videos lying around if you're our
age you might have some vhs's you might
have your bot mitzvah dvd that no longer
works like
legacy box has got you covered here's
how it works you pack and send
all your home movies anything you want
to have digitized you'll send it to
their team they'll digitize everything
by hand and then you
then you enjoy you get back perfectly
preserved digital copies on a thumb
drive a dvd the cloud
they're ready to watch and share and
enjoy they've provided everything they
thought of everything from start to
finish
they have state of the art tracking and
they'll send you updates at every step
of the process
you send your previous recorded moments
to a company you can trust legacy box is
the world's largest
digitizer of home movies and photos and
they have helped more than a million
families
preserve their past and we have an
exclusive offer for you guys so if you
have anniversaries coming up father's
day is coming up for those
who have dads and it's such a nice gift
for someone in your life it's something
like
you really can't even put a price on it
because it's like some the person who
get it will just like cry the second
they see it
yeah so they're offering 40 off so your
family can celebrate a meaningful moment
at a fraction of the normal price
visit legacybox.com toast to get started
today that's a legacy box dot com slash
toast
for 40 off legacybox.com toast
love it so much perfect for the
kardashian recap
so after not really talking about it for
many a season kim and kanye's marriage
has come up
and kim sort of exploded over some
cookies
on the table which led into a
conversation about like she was
relatable also she said she gained 15
pounds but i feel like every time
we see her on camera or in life she's
the most snatch she's ever been
last night's episode was iconic for
three reasons one we got a
huge for us glimpse into what's going on
with kanye yes
two we had a very strange vrbo ad
placement
and three they stayed at the same house
in lake tahoe that the real housewives
of beverly hills are currently staying
at i don't think
this has ever happened before in real
housewives or
real that is really tv history they're
not only a state at the same house
whatever but they were watching their
trips at the exact same time
the real housewives went in october and
this trip is in december i think so
and they're airing at the scene good on
keeping up for getting that [ __ ] out
quick
um this is what kim said about her
marriage by the way what's crazy is that
like chris jenner
potentially could have been on both
trips you know yeah like twice she got
have gone to the same house yeah so
chloe asked him after the cookie
incident how are you and kanye doing she
said there's no fighting like now it's
all calm so i just roll with it
chloe said kim is dealing with so much
right now and it's tough because before
we left her and kanye had this big fight
then they also showed
footage of kim talking to her sisters
about what it unfolded she said i
honestly can't do this anymore
why am i still in this place where i'm
stuck for years
like he goes and moves to a different
state every year i have to be together
so i can raise the kids you know
and he's an amazing dad he's done an
amazing job i think he deserves someone
that can go support his every move go
follow him all over the place and move
to wyoming
i can't do that he should have a wife
that supports his every move and travels
with him and does everything
i feel like a [ __ ] failure that it's
like a third [ __ ] marriage
yeah i feel like a [ __ ] loser but i
can't even think about that like i want
to be happy
i don't feel like you should really she
should count this marriage ending as a
failure because first of all they have
four beautiful children
they had remember they were together for
what like 10 years that's a lot in
hollywood and i know like kim
ever it's so funny because kim like you
know came to fame as like this
like sex symbol when she's always been
like very monogamous and like all she
really wanted was like a nice family
life which is just not what you see like
for a sex symbol yeah
so i don't know i wouldn't count this as
a failure it is really sad
and i think there's so much going on but
i do think like probably the crux of
their issue is like connie is this
artist he wants to just go to paris at
any moment and buy a ranch and
and move and kim is like this really
stable figure like she's this
mother she's a sister she is so has her
feet like firmly planted
in calabasas in reality in her
businesses she's really like a very
stable person and
and i don't think that's very common in
hollywood and in like celebrity life and
and she's right like kanye is this
eclectic person and he should have
someone who's like oh you want to buy a
house in idaho let's go like
that's not kim it's never been kim and i
feel like she kind of changed as much as
she could
for the relationship and kanye is like
this artist who like didn't change at
all you know but he's always been like
that and she's always been like this so
how was it working for so long
or was it even working and maybe like
now that the kids are older it feels
like a more acceptable time to move on
also i can understand that like they're
so different and they're leading
different lives now and their lives have
become increasingly different
but when they said that they got into
like a really big fight before they left
like i wonder what the fights are about
i'm sure he's just like i live here and
you live there come live with me
but she could say the same thing yeah of
course i'm sure that's literally what
she said
yeah and i think that it worked for a
while you know
connie's always been this like eccentric
personality but it's definitely become
on a
like a bigger level in the last few
years like doing less music
and then the uh
sunday service like he's just changed a
lot yeah and people change and that's
fine
but if you're not changing together like
then
you're drifting apart ooh that was like
stunning yeah that was good
it just it was making me sex on the one
hand i was like
enjoying having a glimpse into the
relationship and on the other hand it
was like
really sad to watch no and then i was
getting like i almost don't want to know
then i was getting like flashbacks to
her in new york like with chris
humphries like literally
flashback like uh what does she say like
um that's where like the crying
emoji has come from yeah she's like
sitting in here makeup at the same time
she literally said i feel like a [ __ ]
failure
yeah because i love someone and i change
my mind
like yeah like it's literally the same
thing she's literally the same person
she hasn't changed at all
yeah no it's really funny and then in
next week's episode it seems like she's
talking about it more
and she says i've come too far to only
come this far
and i was like damn and then it's like
i've worked too hard for this zip code
to go
no but that was like such an interesting
quote that had me thinking for a second
it's like she's come so far
but not as far as she wants to and i
don't know if we've spoken about this
but there are
i don't know if we report on it but
there are rumors that irena sheikh and
kanye west are
together an item we haven't spoken about
it yet i saw it
i don't know why i just believe it and
there's like a source
speaking on kim's perhaps being like kim
is like unfazed like happy for him
i'm sure she is and i'm literally sure
that this entire story is true first of
all i really shake a stunning and
they make a great couple like great um
and i
i can see this this was almost a year
ago and it's been going on for so long
at some point like you're just
you want like you're tired like you just
want the other person to be happy you
just want to be happy
so i could really see kim being
relatively unfazed by this i could too
i think that given everything that she
said i think she's been unhappy for some
time and like
wants just her independence and her
happiness and if that means and i think
she wants connie to be happy too
i don't know really anything but just
the way that i see it it doesn't seem
super contentious that's why i was
surprised when i said they were fighting
a lot
so i think i think i don't know why i
just immediately believe that and
i would be happy for them yeah it just
was really sad because i think like
honestly and
it always comes back to what karen huger
said sometimes like your marriage is an
institution and i really feel like
kim and kanye were this institution like
at the center of their family of their
businesses like they just really were
this
institution and it and i think what
we're seeing now which was filmed in
october like we're just seeing the
reality of like your marriage end but
also like the institution coming down
yeah and i think that's why she feels
like a failure because it's not just
like a third marriage it's like the
whole world is
public in this marriage but i wouldn't
consider it a third marriage because the
first one like really didn't count she
like got eloped in vegas and like
they were married for like a year
doesn't count and the chris humphries
thing was merely
a career move like i don't think but
technically it's a third marriage
like i understand it doesn't i'm sure it
doesn't feel like that term either to me
this is like her first real like
marriage but it's technically third yeah
and who knows maybe she'll wind up being
like evelyn hugo
literally um the rest of the episode
like was
whatever i do think what's happening
with their houses is like really
interesting like yeah their contractor
ran away with their deed
that [ __ ] sucks i i it was crazy to
hear that cause i just feel like they
have their [ __ ] on lock like yeah you
know chris doesn't get swindled they
can't be crossed
they can't be crossed so i was just like
oh wow someone swindled chris jenner was
kylie not on the trip
she comes later because she's in the
face the face time tick tock
yeah and then like oh that was in tahoe
yeah
got it yeah oh i forgot not only the
finale's coming up but we get the andy
cohen reunion
yeah that'll be fun yeah i wonder if kim
will talk more about the kanye stuff
andy if anyone can bring it out of
anyone it's andy and it's clear that she
is now talking about it yeah but she's
and she said this in the beginning she's
very protective of the father of her
children she doesn't want to disrespect
him but like this is her life
and she's respected his privacy for so
long for so long but like at the end of
the day like
she's got to do what she's got to do
yeah to an extent
to an extent while still protecting her
family yeah and i think even us as
viewers it's like yeah we want to see
your life but we also are
would never expect to see that yeah um i
had no idea tristan played for the
boston celtics oh i did when i like i
don't know why i knew that i think we
talked about it on the show and that's
like the furthest place he could have
gotten
he was like i want to say in l.a i was
like you're not gonna
no and like of all the places he could
have gone geographically like he got
drafted or traded to the furthest team
from l.a
yeah and when chloe's like to move true
to be in a condo i was like i hear you
no and also like she would move to
boston and then he would still be gone
half the year for away games so it's
like what's the point
and then in two years and i just feel
like at this stage in her life she's
beyond like
following people around yeah like she
she did that
she tried that she tried it and i do
believe
um the boston celtics are like not very
good so he's probably back in l.a right
now i don't know if they're even in the
playoffs
yeah they'll make it work they'll be
fine mm-hmm um nothing else really
happened in episode except the scavenger
hunt which was fun like testing my own
trivia
questions i actually like forgot so much
of that stuff that happened especially
in like
the early seasons when they lived in
that ranch yeah i love that house i
liked the
scavenger hunt and i just also want to
say about the chloe the courtney and
scott stuff
um when courtney was sitting down with
her sisters trying to explain because it
seems like for the end of the show they
want to wrap up that
line like how do courtney and scott end
up and like courtney was trying to
explain to her sisters that like
they've had this conversation and that
scott hasn't done the things that she
needs him to do
and one like what are those things like
need to know and it was up to kim and
chloe to ask her that and instead they
totally were not listening to her they
were not listening
they were listening it was really really
annoying yeah i feel like the producers
told kim get an answer
go in there and get an answer from her
and so she wasn't listening to what her
sister was saying and i was like
no i actually feel like it is really
annoying for courtney so it's like
everyone in the family wants them to be
together and it makes it seem like
scott's so down so courtney's like the
[ __ ] who doesn't why we're all waiting
on courtney when there's so much
obviously going on they're not gonna get
back together on camera like there's so
much going on behind the scenes i'm sure
she still has problems with him
scott is has made huge w like uh
progress
in his journey but like he there's still
weird things about him like he dates 11
year olds you know like
yeah there's weird so like i can
understand courtney still not being
comfortable
i need to know what those things are
that she said need to happen in order
for them to be together
yeah but now it's just like watching it
knowing like courtney and travis of it
all like it seems so silly like we know
that they're like not even close they've
never been further apart from being
together they're both in like serious
relationships
yeah well one of them is yeah and the
other one's dating at 18 year olds can't
wait to hear all about it on
real housewives of beverly hills there's
so much kardashian beverly hills
crossover as it should be um i can't
wait to hear lisa rena like try and
pretend
that like she thinks it's inappropriate
when you know it's like the best thing
that ever happened to her entire family
yeah but it's looking forward to it i'm
still not keeping up
not interested not chipping not shipping
it's inappropriate
yeah and it's like him and sophia broke
up i was re-watching old epic
earlier episodes in this season and he
explains him and sophia broke up because
pretty much
she wanted him to choose between her and
courtney like you can't have a wife and
a girlfriend yeah
and he chose courtney and then now
courtney is with travis and it seems
like from what i've read
courtney and scott are less close and
like scott's kind of upset about it and
he's he's been in miami like with amelia
so she chose travis
she chose her relationship and so now
i'm like obviously sophia doesn't want
to be second fiddle
but i'm like scott and sophia get back
together that's very interesting
and what's so funny is like sophia is in
her own right like
very famous very wealthy like whatever
so she kind of had the leverage to walk
away from the relationship being like
you have to choose
amelia needs this relationship
career-wise so much she would never say
like choose my course no and it's like
every time the relationship gets serious
enough that the girlfriend would want
more
scott will just say no and then move on
to the next 18 year old
so it's like they're all that's sensible
but i literally that's how i see scott
and emilia's relationship it's like he
has the same relationship that he had
but without someone like wanting
more from him yes with someone who needs
him more than he needs her
and whenever it gets to that point he'll
just move on from the relationship until
the day that he wakes up and is like i
don't want to do this anymore yeah i
don't want to run around the world and
be
like a single man yeah a bachelor so and
whoever's there that morning will be his
wife
george clooney vibes like it was almost
stacey keebler
uh i don't know if it's george clooney
vice because he was always in such
serious relationships these are serious
too
it reminds me of what we always say
about dan lazarian
like he's just going to wake up do we i
don't talk about dan
bilzerian i was talking about it when i
co-hosted with justin sylvester we were
talking about him just clear that up we
don't always talk about
dan bilzer okay when justin sylvester co
hosted with me we had a conversation
about dan bilzerian and how like one day
he's just gonna wake up and like
whichever model is beside him will be
his wife okay and that's how i feel
about scott
that's the funny thing that he brought
up just in sylvester because i was
thinking of something on the plane when
i had made my eulogy and i said like you
have to replace me with someone who
is we're related to the exception would
be i would
in heaven allow you to give my seat to
justin sylvester i'm going to tell you
that
the show would actually be better i
would 100 percent give your seat and
mine to him but like i don't know
if he'll accept the position yeah no i
just wanted to put it out there in case
you know something happens to me this
weekend you know
yeah i fully give this seat to margot
olivia
and justin sylvester and kayla thank you
and theo
theo he always has a seat always at my
table speaking of i
am hosting shabbat at my house today so
i've just got a lot of you know
housewives i'm literally uh jennifer
goodwin
in why women kill you'll understand the
reference after you watch also she's in
the show
yeah so i forgot that you like it i
forgot to mention that um
it's amazing that i like the show as
much as i do when jennifer goodwin is
one of the stars because i find her so
insufferably annoying and she almost
ruined one of my favorite movies
something borrowed but
her character was so unlikable in that
movie that it actually like worked out
um but you're supposed to like be on her
side in wyoming kill and
she's probably her and maggie gyllenhaal
are two of my least favorite actresses
in hollywood
is jennifer the modern perspective in
why women no she's in the 50s she's like
the oldest one
oh okay she's so annoying that she
actually she gets better on the show
like you actually really like end up
liking her because she's like
this like sad sack um but yeah
you'll you'll see okay i just i wanted
to put it out there that i know that i'm
contradicting myself me and my
principles like
but the show is too good even jennifer
goodwin can't bring it down
okay wow that's a ringing endorsement
yeah and that's a show right
that's our show are we nobody else's
nobody else's show there's always all
these claims like so-and-so says
everyone is like trying to say like
that's my show that's my show but don't
get it twisted
that's our show thank you guys so much
for listening to the morning toast
millennium morning show where we deliver
the past five stories that you need to
know every monday through friday on
youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up we're also
available as a podcast anywhere podcast
can be found so that's spotify itunes
stitcher or public radio i heard you
catch box all the places where we listed
podcasts
find us the morning shows leave a five
star review about how beautiful stunning
and smart we are
hope you guys have an amazing weekend
stay safe get drunk don't drink and
drive take care of yourselves be nice to
one another
and we'll see you on monday goodbye